bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin une
audition qui s'est déroulée elle la
semaine dernière dans le cadre des
travaux de la commission d' enquête sur
les autorités administratives
indépendantes ne commission d' enquête
qui a été créée à l'initiative du groupe
rdse et qui a d'ailleurs pour rapporteur
de président de ce même groupe le
sénateur jacques mézard là ce matin à
l'audition de la haute autorité de santé
une autorité qui a été créé en 2004 qui
a trois missions principales d'abord
évaluer quels médicaments etc et les
actes doivent être remboursés par
l'assurance maladie
ensuite est bien certifié les
établissements de santé en fonction de
la qualité de leurs soins de la qualité
de leur prise en charge enfin faire des
recommandations en matière de santé
publique cette autorité a donc
essentiellement des missions de conseil
pour les autorités sanitaires à la
relativement peu de marge de manoeuvre
et dernièrement elle a eu des
difficultés à faire entendre sa voir
notamment au printemps dernier lors de
la polémique sur la politique vaccinale
notez enfin que le président de cette
autorité le professeur jean luc
harousseau auditionné la semaine
dernière a depuis démissionné
officiellement pour des raisons
personnelles tout de suite donc retour à
cette audition la haute autorité de
santé je rappelle d'une autorité
publique indépendante à caractère
scientifique
doté de la personnalité morale et qui a
été créé en 2004 elle a pour mission
d'assurer à tous les patients et usagers
un accès pérenne équitable à des soins
aussi efficace sûr et efficient que
possible grâce à l'évaluation des
produits de santé des pratiques
professionnelles de l'organisation des
soins de la santé publique en fait les
trois missions principales de la haute
autorité la santé sont l'évaluation
médicale économique et de santé publique
ensuite l'amélioration de la qualité la
sécurité les soirs et enfin de
l'information des publics alors depuis
2005 l'émission de la haute autorité de
santé n'ont cessé d'être élargie pour
plus de 10 me par par plus de dix
modification législative des
élargissements sont à nouveau prévues
dans le projet de santé de loi de santé
en cours d'examen actuellement vous
lisez vos corps et j'imagine dans votre
propos liminaire en tout cas je vous
rappeler que la haute autorité de santé
dispose de l'autonomie financière son
budget d' arrêter par un collège sur
proposition du directeur en 2014 les
dépenses s'élevaient à 50,7 millions
d'euros contre 61 6 millions d'euros en
2010 et l'origine des ressources a
également été modifié récemment on y
reviendra sûrement monsieur le président
comme la loi le permet votre audition
fera l'objet d'un compte rendu publié
dans le compte rendu détaillé des
réunions des commissions qui est diffusé
en version papier sur le site internet
du sénat par ailleurs votre audition est
ouverte à la presse et au public et elle
fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo avant
de passer la parole le formalisme des
commissions d enquête me conduit à vous
demander de prêter serment je suis
également tenus de vous indiquer que
tout faux témoignage devant d'autres
commissions seraient passibles des
peines prévues aux articles 434 13 à 434
15 du code pénal je crois que votre
directeur général monsieur dominique
many pardon peut être appelé à parler
donc je vais vous demander aussi de
prêter serment donc en conséquence je
vous invite avec monsieur dominique
baigne directeur général a prêté serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dites-leur
après l'autre je le jure je le jure
je vous en remercie selon l'usagé
habituel je vous propose monsieur le
président de faire de nous faire part de
vos observations durant une dizaine de
minutes et après quoi notre rapporteur
jacques mézard et les membres de la
commission qui le souhaitent vous
poseront leurs questions vous avez la
parole
merci madame la présidente je crois que
vous avez fort bien résumé les missions
de la haute autorité de santé et vous
avez rappelé son statut juridique
d'autorité publique indépendante mais à
caractère scientifique et donc je
voudrais peut-être en introduction
introduire sur les deux mots qui pour
nous définissent de manière très claire
ce qu'est la haute autorité de santé
c'est donc une institution scientifique
et c'est une institution indépendante
ça entraîne pour nous deux exigences la
première c'est celle de la rigueur
scientifique
qui nous amène nous entoure et d'une
méthodologie extrêmement précise et qui
nous incite à faire appel à des experts
qui nous permettent de définir l'état de
l'art et comme vous l'avez dit vous-même
de
aider le décideur
concernant les produits de santé aider
les professionnels de santé concernant
leur pratique est également
informer les patients sur l'état de
l'art
deuxième mot et 2e pilier la
constitution de la haute autorité de
santé c'est l'indépendance nous nous
devons d'être indépendant a bien sûr par
rapport à l'industrie pharmaceutique
l'industrie des dispositifs médicaux
mais aussi par rapport à toutes les
pressions éventuelles
qu'elle soit
au dessus de nous les pressions des
ministères de la santé ou du ministère
du budget
et des directions qui travaillent au
sein de ce ministère que ce soit les
professionnels de santé que ce soit les
malades qui peuvent avoir intérêt à
influer sur nos décisions alors cette
double
nécessité rigueur scientifique et
l'indépendance intellectuelle
pose pour nous un certain nombre de
problèmes
notamment depuis la crise du médiator
puisque déjà avant la crise du médiateur
la haute autorité santé
autorité indépendante s'était entouré de
toutes les précautions pour éviter les
liens d'intérêts qui mettrait ses
experts internes ou externes en
situation de conflit ce d'audience en
situation
de biais de l'analyse
et depuis la loi de renforcement de la
sécurité sanitaire
mais surtout depuis la crise elle-même
qui a généré un certain nombre de
suspicions à la fois chez les décideurs
mais aussi dans les médias et dans le
grand public
nous avons un fonctionnement qui devient
plus difficile et nous sommes pris en
permanence
entre deux risques le risque de choisir
des experts qui serait sans conflit
d'intérêt mais connaît très mal les
sujets et le risque de choisir des
experts très compétent mais qui ont des
liens d'intérêt avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique
dans la première situation
nos recommandations
risquerait d'être critiqué par les
scientifiques pour ne pas avoir été
faite par lé les vrais experts et nous
avons cette situation souvent j'ajoute
que certaines sociétés savantes
refuse de collaborer avec nous parce que
elle considère que nos critères de
sélection sont trop rigides à l'opposé
nous avons bien sûr le risque
d'avoir des experts qui ont des conflits
d'intérêts qui aurait pu nous échapper
ne serait ce que parce qu'ils les ont
déclarés trop tardivement et qui nous
met dans une situation difficile
vis-à-vis de plaintes éventuelles et en
particulier de plainte auprès du conseil
d'état comme nous avons connu une en
2011 donc voilà je voulais rappeler ça
en introduction parce que ces deux
piliers de la constitution de la haute
autorité de santé sont absolument
fondamentaux ont dit à la maison
has qui sont dans notre code génétique
donc nous y tenons énormément et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
quelquefois était accusé d'une trop
grande lenteur parce que nous avons pris
un soin
considérable pour respecter les
procédures méthodologique qui sont les
certaine façon les garantes
de la rigueur scientifique et de l'autre
côté respecter une analyse selon les
critères que nous avons nous-mêmes
défini pour être sûr de l'indépendance
de nos experts
voilà je suis passé le point important
alors nous sommes très attachés au
statut d'autorité publique indépendante
à caractère scientifique parce que nous
pensons que
ces deux caractéristiques
nous permettent d'aider à la décision
les gouvernants à commencer par les
parlementaires savait que nous devons
faire un rapport tous les ans
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
commission des affaires sociales de nos
deux assemblées est évidemment
le rapport que nous faisons c'est sur
notre activité et c'est une activité qui
a été définie par ces deux
caractéristiques que je donnais je pense
que les lois que vous avez à voter
concerne
lorsqu'elle concerne la haute autorité
de santé
sont
particulièrement
inspirés par ces deux caractéristiques
et quand on confie une mission à la
haute autorité de santé et on en confie
tous les ans chaque projet de loi
notamment dans chaque projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale on
confie une mission parce qu'on sait que
la haute autorité de santé
donnera un avis qui est la vie reconnu
scientifique sur lequel on pourra se
fonder sur lequel on pourra prendre des
décisions mais nos travaux certes aussi
beaucoup aux professionnels de santé et
beaucoup de sociétés savantes ou du
conseil national professionnel cherche à
avoir la validation de leurs propres
travaux par la haute autorité de santé
parce que c'est un garant à la fois
scientifique mais aussi juridique pour
aider les professionnels de santé
notamment les médecins dans les
différentes procédures qu'ils peuvent
éventuellement subir
c'est le premier point je voulais
développer alors je voudrais développer
un deuxième point puisque j'ai vu que
vous souhaitiez poser des questions
notamment sur les moyens budgétaires
je vais assister sous le contrôle de
dominique ming directeur de la haute
autorité de santé mais aussi de
véronique sonnailles kyi secrétaire
générale qui en particulier s'occupe des
questions de moyens de budget de
personnel et de le court
je voudrais insister sur les efforts que
nous avons faits depuis pratiquement le
début de mon mandat
pour
contrôler nos dépenses et vous avez vous
même allusion à la diminution de nos
budgets en dépenses
dans le contexte que nous connaissions
au début de notre prise de fonction en
2011 dans tout de suite pensé qu'il
était important de faire un effort
particulier notamment sur les frais de
fonctionnement pour pouvoir garder une
certaine possibilités dans le
dans l'investissement mais aussi dans
l'est ce qui fait nous notre notre notre
métier c'est à dire les personnels qui
contribuent aux productions de la haute
autorité de santé
alors parallèlement les dotations
budgétaires
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer n'ont pas
augmenté
et donc nous commençons à voir quelques
inquiétudes pour l'avenir et nous avons
fait une demande très précise de
maintenir les dotations au niveau où
elles sont actuellement faute de quoi
nous risquerions après avoir épuisé le
fonds de roulement qui est le nôtre
actuellement nous risquerions de ne plus
pouvoir
remplir nos fonctions donc cette ou
certaines de nos fonctions cet effort
s'est matérialisée par
une limitation des personnels mais aussi
par
un déplacement de la haute autorité de
santé comme vous le savez nous sommes à
saint denis près du stade de france mais
nous étions sur deux sites et dans un
souci de plus grande efficacité depuis
van déficiences nous avons souhaité
déménager prendre une autre location un
autre bail dans un seul site qui est pas
très loin de là où nous sommes en face
la station du rer b et nous ferons avec
ce déménagement qui doit avoir lieu en
novembre
non seulement
meilleur outil de travail pour les
membres de la haute autorité de santé
mais aussi des économies substantielles
sur notre loyer donc voilà je
le système pas trop mais si vous avez
des questions précises dominique mangue
pourra y répondre je souhaitais insisté
là dessus parce que
ces efforts ont été faits en toute
connaissance de cause mais je répète que
s'il y a une trop grande diminution de
nos dotations l'avenir de cette
institution que l'on demande de plus en
plus d'efforts tous les ans pourrait
être en danger
c'était les deux messages principaux que
je voulais donner en introduction nous
avons pris connaissance les nombreuses
questions que vous posez dans le cadre
de cette mission je sais pas si vous
voulez tout nous les poser mais on peut
y répondre soit par points soit de
manière globale notamment concernant la
composition du collège que j'ai
l'honneur de présider qui est constitué
de huit membres qui sont nommés par les
plus hautes autorités de l'état puisque
deux membres sont nommés par le
président de la république de nantes
sont nommés par le président du sénat de
membres sont nommés par le président de
l'assemblée nationale et deux membres
sont nommés par le président du conseil
économique social et environnemental
ses huit membres notamment delà de six
ans et ils sont renouvelés par moitié
tous les trois ans il ya eu un
renouvellement l'an dernier et donc le
prochain renouvellement est prévue en
février 2010 est sauf si la loi santé
qui comporte une ordonnance enfin
article 42 faisant allusion à une
ordonnance sur la gouvernance de la
haute autorité de santé a mené à
modifications plus précoce la
composition du collège
merci monsieur présente pour la carte et
de vous ou pour liminaire monsieur le
rapporteur
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président vous venez de nous dire que
s'il y avait une poursuite de la baisse
des crédits ça remettrait en cause
le fonctionnement de votre autorité
vaut ce financement est aujourd'hui
assuré pratiquement uniquement par des
crédits versés par l'assurance maladie
cela vous permet-il de disposer de
l'autonomie financière
prévue par la loi et comment négocier
vous pour déterminer ce budget
alors là la loi effectivement apporter
un changement
mode de dotation de la haute autorité de
santé puisque en fait une partie de
notre budget était constitué d'une
dotation de l'état une dotation double
de l'assurance maladie mais une autre
partie quand été constitué par le
produit d'une taxe sur la promotion de
l'industrie pharmaceutique nous avions
considéré que notamment dans le contexte
la crise du médiateur
tirer ses ressources de l'industrie
pharmaceutique posait quelques problèmes
presque dire éthiques donc nous étions
très demandeurs de cette modification du
financement de la haute autorité de
santé il y avait une autre raison
c'est là encore je parle sous le
contrôle de véronique chenail mais c'est
que cette taxe donner un produit
extrêmement variables et non prévisible
et on a eu en particulier une année des
rentrées financières très importantes
qui nous ont généré un fonds de
roulement auquel on ne s'attendait pas
alors la dotation actuelle est
effectivement plus simple
et elle assemble dotations de l'état et
de l'assemblée nationale elle compte
aussi la dotation spécifique pour la
certification des établissements de
santé et c'est vrai que nous avons
actuellement un fonds de roulement nous
pouvons pour encore
deux ou trois ans trois ans nous
pourrons encore fonctionner si les
dotations par dans ces dotations resto
ni voilà si les dotations reste à ce
niveau
après trois ans si les dotations reste à
ce niveau là on pourra plus parce
qu'actuellement
effectivement nous dépensons plus que
nous ne recevons donc dans trois ans on
sera dans une situation très difficile
si par ailleurs avant trois ans les
dotations diminué alors on serait plus
rapidement que ça en situation difficile
peut-être que domenech veut compléter
s'agissant des conditions de la
négociation tout au moins deux ils ont
deux décisions
c'est pas les choses sont pas aussi
simple que ça monsieur le sénateur vous
l'imaginer assis la négociation dans la
mesure où vous n'avez pas le couteau
sous la gorge c'est certes oui mais le
jour où vous aurez dépensé
vos économies si l'on peut appeler ça
des économies oui
comment envisagez vous la négociation
c'est dès à présent que la question se
pose parce qu'une institution comme la
nôtre 400 collaborateurs un budget de
l'ordre de 55 à 60 millions d'euros en
comptant les investissements
des angles des programmes plus révèle d
d d engagement dans la durée de toute
façon d'ores et déjà nous allons nous le
regard sur l'année 2018 nous sommes sur
des perspectives triennal ce qui est
d'ailleurs conforme aux lois aujourd'hui
de financer et à la
aux différentes méthodes d'appréciation
qui sont aujourd'hui en place pour la
gestion budgétaire et comptable dans les
collectivités comme la nôtre donc on est
sur lui triennal donc on a saisi les
ministres en charge essentiellement donc
il s'agit unis sera santé n'avons pas de
tutelle au sens d'un pays mais enfin
nous avons encore enfin une direction de
cette administration centrale qui
coordonne les questions de ressources de
la haute autorité de santé c'est la
direction de la sécurité sociale
associée à la direction générale de
l'offre de soins puisqu'il ya une partie
qui est présent lien avec la
certification de l'établissement de
santé qui est présente en lien avec le
l'offre hospitalière donc la dss et la
dg os
discutent avec nous en lien avec le
ministère des
comptes publics est et dans le cadre de
la 2 de la préparation du plfss pour
avoir une dotation qui est logée au sein
de juillet le septième sceau objectif de
l'andam enfin de l'objectif de dépenses
de courts et moyens séjours dmc haut
dans lequel notre financement n'est pas
individualiser en tant que tel mais il
est mentionné donc il n'y a pas de
négociations il ya une information des
autorités parlementaires sur la demande
de financement et par ailleurs nous
avons alertés n'ont donc non direction
technique en leur faisant valoir que nos
avions et c'est ce que disait le
président l'instant nous avions une
nécessité vitale d'avoir une visibilité
triennale des ressources dans la mesure
où les engagements de l'année 2015
auront des effets sur l'année 2018 et
plus tard donc
c'est dans ce cadre là nous que que nous
nous situons alors n'aurons pas de
réponse immédiate puisque c'est lié
notamment aux négociations du plfss qui
vont qui vont qu'ils vont démarrer là
mais pour nous c'est une exigence de sud
quotidien dans et déjà de savoir comment
nous terminerons l'année 2018
ajouté de manière plus générale un point
important c'est que je faisais allusion
tout à l'heure aux nouvelles missions
qui nous sont confiées tous les ans
évidemment nous les avons intégrés dans
notre
programme de travail
on va dire personnel constant voire
personnelle un peu diminué ça veut dire
que toutes ces missions pour l'acte pour
lesquels nous n'avons pas eu dotations
budgétaires supplémentaires nous les
avons assumé au prix de redéploiements
internes je vais en citer deux nous
avons mis en place un site d'information
des patients sur la qualité des soins
délivrés dans les hôpitaux qu'on appelle
le site scop santé ça a été par du
redéploiement interne et d'ailleurs du
redéveloppement budgétaire également
puisqu'il a fallu payer l'information
qui nous est donnée par
l'apei h l'association pour
l'information hospitalière et le
deuxième exemple c'est l'évaluation
médico économique qui est une mission
très importante qui a été développé et
en particulier il nous a été confiée par
le plfss 2012 la mission de faire une
évaluation médico-économique des
produits de santé notamment des
médicaments les plus innovants mais
aussi les plus chers donc nous avons été
obligé de réorganiser complètement nos
services pour pouvoir remplir cette
mission que nous remplissons je crois
avec ce tir à la sélection tout le monde
entend dans l'utile si je puis dire
voilà donc les questions budgétaires
sont évidemment des questions très
importantes pour nous
oui est-ce que estimez-vous aujourd'hui
que vous avez les moyens de remplir
correctement les missions qui vous sont
impartis
je passerai la parole dominique maigne
c'est une question délicate la haute
autorité de santé afin en tout cas le
président et le directeur n'ont pas eu
pour habitude de se plaindre de leur
dotation
je viens quand même de dire que nous
avons accepté des missions
supplémentaires sans moyens
supplémentaires et que la prochaine loi
modernisation du système de santé
français va sans doute nous apporter une
mission supplémentaire très importante
qui scelle d'évaluer les stratégies
diagnostiques et thérapeutiques
efficiente que ce sera là encore une
charge de travail importante
donc c'est vrai qu on est comme l'a dit
dominique maigne on est inquiet et donc
ça a été je sais pas si vous comptiez ne
poser la question mais c'était
l'occasion pour nous chaque fois que
nous avons été interrogés sur les
relations qui existent entre la haute
autorité de santé et d'autres
institutions sanitaires c'était
l'occasion pour nous de dire qu'il
fallait chercher des mises en commun des
mutualisations pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse l'utiliser au mieux les moyens
qui existent non seulement dans notre
institution mais aussi dans les
institutions voisines c'est en ce sens
que nous avons souhaité nous rapprocher
de la nes mme qui prend en charge les
problèmes des établissements médico
sociaux que nous les abritent ont
actuellement pas encore va les abriter
dans nos nouveaux locaux mais on prend
en charge leurs fonctions support et
nous souhaitons bien effectivement que
lorsque
le
jp puisqu'ils sont gérées par un parent
âgé ip l'orge et ip viendra à expiration
qu'il puisse nous rejoindre et qu'on
puisse travailler ensemble pour
mutualiser
mission et donc les personnels qui qui
travaillent sur ces missions alors de la
même façon il ya un certain nombre
d'institutions qui ont des
préoccupations très proche du nôtre et
il y avait il ya deux ans maintenant une
enquête de ligier fait de l'igas sur
les agences sanitaires les institutions
sanitaires et on avait fait un certain
nombre de propositions pour nous
rapprocher sans pour autant parler de de
fusion au moins nous rapprocher en ayant
bien pas 6 et les missions de chacun de
certaines institutions qui travaillent
sur des sujets très proches des nôtres
que sont la nappe la cale au conseil
pour la santé publique toute une série
d'institutions avec lesquels nous
souhaiterions vous voir travailler plus
étroitement et mieux définir nos
compétences de munich
pardon pour répondre très précisément
votre question avez vous les moyens
d'assumer les missions le projet de loi
de santé qui est un examen chez vous
prévoit près occurrence de saisine de la
chaise sur des missions nouvelles dont
certaines sur des missions lourdes
notamment l'élaboration de stratégies
efficientes en lien avec les sociétés
savantes et les collèges professionnels
et par ailleurs nous sommes de plus en
plus
interpellé sur ce qui est de l'ordre de
son appel vulgairement le big data où
les grands les grandes données et donc
sur les capacités et les compétences à
interroger les bases de données médico
administrative et et à étayer tout tout
tout tout nos avis de larges requêtes
sur ces bases là et d'études qui leur
sont à annexer bon très clairement non
nous n'aurons pas les moyens de répondre
à toutes les missions qui nous sont
demandées par pour aujourd'hui proposée
par le législateur si d'une part il n'y
a pas
à un moment donné que nous considérons
comme étant proche aujourd'hui une
décision sur une forme de socle
budgétaire de cette maison pour assurer
les missions qu'elle assume d'ores et
déjà et par ailleurs des financements
sur les émissions nouvelles la réduction
de voilure coquelles nous allons
procéder entre 2011 et aujourd'hui
notamment a fait baisser alors certes
des
frais de gestion générale des dépenses
communication ont toutes choses qui
peuvent être optimisés et qu'ils ont été
puisque dame ont baissé ken de 12% non
non on en dépense réelle de budget à
budget mais on a également supprimé les
financements de tout ce qui était le
secteur des activités de recherche nous
avons supprimé les financements des
sociétés à sa vente et des collèges
professionnels qui avait besoin d'être
aidé d'avoir des ressources pour
rédiger des recommandations et faire des
travaux que nous leur prescrivent y ont
donc il ya toute une série quand même de
financement qui aujourd'hui ne sont plus
actives et mai et qui correspondent à
des demandes qui sont des demandes
fortes exprimées aujourd'hui par le par
le législateur donc nous aurons besoin
d'une rue budgétisation cela me paraît
absolument indispensable
pour aller un peu plus loin puisque vous
avez pris un peu les devants par rapport
à d'éventuelles fusions partenariat
mutualisation avec d'autres structures
mais j'ai souvenance d'avoir été très
longtemps rapporteur
d'une commission d' enquête sur les
dérives
thérapeutique
et j'ai souvenance d'avoir eu un contact
avec votre haute autorité
votre autorité indépendante
parce que je je m'interrogeais ainsi que
d'autres
sur la raison pour laquelle il n'y avait
pas beaucoup mais parfois pas du tout
d'évaluation de certaines
thérapies voir pseudo thérapies qui se
multiplient sur le territoire national
et sur lesquelles il lui était important
d'avoir une opinion d'une autorité telle
que la vôtre alors je me suis demandé si
c'était par manque de moyens si c'était
par manque d'experts si c'était tout
simplement la volonté
de ne pas mettre le nez là dedans il n'y
a pas de volonté de ne pas mettre le nez
dans des thérapies non académique
mais
on a effectivement
programme de travail annuel
qui vient essentiellement des directions
du ministère de l'assurance maladie
un peu des sociétés savantes et aussi
les industriels qui ont de nombreux
médicaments aux dispositifs médicaux à
évaluer
s'ajoute à cela notre désir d'offrir
la possibilité aux associations de
patients
de nous saisir également et
le désir de la haute autorité de santé
de
ce qu'on appelle une autosaisine de
pouvoir se saisir elle-même de sujets
qui l'intéressent dans ce cadre les
choix sont évidemment très difficile
et la médecine on va dire classique
évoluant très vite et faisant courir
elle même un certain nombre de risques
au patient c'est vrai qu'on a priorisé
les sujets de médecine classique ou bien
que nos demandeurs ses fistons ces
sujets alors après il ya une autre
raison qui fait que à ce jour nous
n'avons effectivement pas fait de
travail sur
thérapeutiques alternatives
c'est que le principe de la haute
autorité de santé et d'être une autorité
scientifique
c'est à dire que s'appuyer sur ce qu'on
appelle en anglais evidence based
medicine la médecine par l'épreuve donc
on est assez gêné pour évaluer des
stratégies thérapeutiques
qui ne reposent pas sur des concepts
scientifiques ou sur des
expérimentations scientifiques la has
est une autorité scientifique et donc
nous jugeons sur des publications sur
des rapports ce qui n'existe pas dans ce
type de dans ce type de données en sans
aller jusqu'à des pratiques
douteuses et dangereuse
on a eu pas mal de relations avec les
dirigeants des sociétés d'homéopathie et
on a été
généralement dans l'incapacité alors il
ya des produits d'homéopathie qui sont
évalués par la haute autorité de santé
meyer a que général on n'a pas de
données scientifiques qui nous permette
de blonay sur sur l'intérêt même si
individuellement les membres du collège
peuvent avoir des avis
oui mais c'est que c'est c'est déjà bien
de faire savoir que vous considérez que
ce n'est pas dans le domaine de la
science enfin quand on est une autorité
de santé avec
le poids qui le vôtre il est quand même
pas notre aussi de procéder à des
évaluations
ne serait ce que pour préserver la santé
de nos concitoyens
parce que quand même un certain nombre
de dérives y compris avec des
laboratoires entre guillemets puissant
qui mériterait que un oeil scientifiques
se penchent dessus
directement concernés dans par nos
missions lorsqu'on est dans le champ de
la sécurité
sanitaire donc développé des actes qui
pourrait faire courir des risques aux
patients donc on a été appelée à le
faire dans n'ont pas nécessairement dans
le champ des
thérapeutiques non conventionnelles mais
on l'a fait dans le champ de la médecine
esthétique avec des actes qui pour
lequel nous avons recommandé avec des
bonheurs divers au plan juridique parce
que tout ceci est très complexe de de
les encadrer ou d interdire nous avons
été également interpellé par les
pouvoirs publics sur les rejoindre là on
est à la limite de ce dont vous parlez
des échographies avisé
non médical
des embryons c'est à dire les échos
qu'on fait aux femmes enceintes pour
faire l'album de famille
avec des risques au possible sur la
sueur sur la mer il ya donc comme ça d
un certain nombre de dax où donc de
saisine dans lequel nous pouvons être
concernées mais c'est vrai que d'une
manière générale donc d'une part c'est
effectivement le fruit du programme de
travail et d'autre part c'est le
problème des données
l'absence de données fait qu'il est très
difficile de rendre la vie c'est la
raison pour laquelle du reste le juge
administratif nous a censuré dans les
avis nous allons rendu sur certains
actes de médecine esthétique ils étaient
fondées plus sur la conviction que sur
les données
mais comme vous nous avez dit que le
programme de travail venait en partie du
ministère
ça veut dire que le ministère n'est pas
tellement préoccupé par cela ce qui ne
m'étonne pas mais
pour en revenir directement
certains problèmes que vous avez soulevé
parce que vous nous avez dit à juste
titre que c'était pas facile
d'avoir des experts
pouvant cumuler une expérience et une
compétence de grande qualité et aussi
aucun lien avec qui que ce soit et on le
comprend on ne comprend parfaitement
alors qu'elle
commet
pour garantir l'impartialité de vos
décisions
comment
fonctionnez-vous notamment vis-à-vis des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
alors c'est évidemment une question qui
était posée dès la création de la haute
autorité de santé sur laquelle dès le
début de mon mandat j'avais
souhaité qu'on retravaille
ce qui fait qu'actuellement
bien sûr tous les experts
internes les membres de nos commissions
ou externe que nous sollicitons pour des
groupes de travail doivent nous remettre
une déclaration publique d'intérêts
et nous analysons pour chacun d'entre
eux en détail ses déclarations publiques
d'intérêts pour savoir si le comportent
des relations avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique qui pourrait être sur un
sujet précis
un conflit majeur d'intérêt donc pour
essayer de nous guider dans cette
évaluation nous avons produit un
document qui est un guide de gestion des
conflits d'intérêts qui
fait l'objet d'une réflexion d'un an et
qui est
on va dire créé c'est
souvent sévère
qui détaille les différentes situations
en relation avec ce qui est dans la
trame d'une déclaration d'intérêts et
qui explique pour chacun des points quel
lien peut constituer un conflit majeur
pour regard de la question discutée
ça nous a évidemment permis d'avoir plus
de sécurité mais je répète que ça nous a
créé pas mal de problèmes et ça nous
génère temps passé considérable c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous nous
souhaitons travailler un peu plus avec
les sociétés savantes et les conseils
nationaux professionnels pour leur
demander de nous aider en sélectionnant
des experts
dont ils savent qu'ils sont compétents
et dont ils savent aussi qu'ils n'ont
pas de liens d'intérêt même si de toute
façon en fera le contrôle
pour aller plus loin nous avons mis en
place en interne une petite structure
avec
professeurs d'université anciens
conseillers des ministères donc avec une
grande rigueur morale qui est en charge
tous ces problèmes de on va dire
éthique et
expertise et puis nous avons mis en
place presque depuis la création de la
haute autorité de santé
comité
de déontologie et avant la loi de
renforcement de la sécurité sociale
comité de déontologie et de gestion des
conflits d'intérêts qui est depuis que
je suis président de la haute autorité
de santé présidée par un membre du
conseil d'état et qui fait travailler
des personnes extérieures à la haute
autorité de santé et notamment des
juristes des représentants des patients
et aussi des représentants des médecins
donc c'est ce comité est interrogé
chaque fois que de besoin lorsqu'on est
dans une situation un peu difficile à
analyser ce qui d'ailleurs assez rare on
les fait plutôt travailler sur des sur
des problèmes de fond alors en pratique
nos commissions et le collège lui même
sont amenés à après analyse des
déclarations d'intérêt sur un sujet
précis à s'autocensurer c'est à dire que
si un membre de la commission est en
situation de conflit d'intérêt par
rapport aux sujets débattus il sort de
la salle ne participe pas au débat et
bien sûr ils ne participent pas au vote
donc voilà c'est une gestion qui est
plutôt sévère et ça explique pourquoi
certains médecins certain nombre de
sociétés savantes s'estime blessés par
les décisions que nous sommes amenés à
prendre puisque on est amené à rejeter
la candidature de très grands
professeurs qui ne comprennent pas qu'on
puisse les suspects et on le suspecte
pas mais on considère que la relation
avec la russie fera sauter pourrait
générer une suspicion vis-à-vis de
conflit d'intérêts donc voilà c'est une
politique très
on va dire très précises qui pour nous
est un poids considérable
ce que vous pouvez nous faire le point
sur les les contentieux qui sont
adressés à votre
autorité à raison de ses décisions en
particulier en matière de certification
est ce qu'il y à des risques financiers
qui sont associés à ces contentieux en
matière de certification des
établissements de santé à ma
connaissance il ya eu un seul
contentieux dans un juge administratif
qui était
celui d'un établissement important
puisque chu bon qui n'a pas qui n'a pas
prospéré
mais très très peu de contentieux devant
le juge nous avons dans le cadre de la
procédure de certification
une procédure d'appel
devant devant
les instances de la certification qui
est une forme de recours gracieux
exerçait devant l'autorité hiérarchique
et qui la plupart du temps
résout les problèmes
d'incompréhension qui peuvent survenir
entre les experts visiteurs et
l'établissement alors yat-il at-il un
risque financier les décisions qui sont
prises puisque là on est dans le champ
de décision des plus beaux chants d'avis
les 2650 établissements de santé
français on sent certifié par là par la
has en direct
il nous sommes très attentifs au fait
que l'édition de certification ont un
effet structurant restructurant mais ils
ne doivent pas percuter des procédures
qui sont notamment les procédures devant
les tribunaux de commerce donc lorsqu'un
établissement de santé privé en
l'occurrence et et deux dans une
procédure
devant le tribunal de commerce
généralement suspens la certification
dans la tente des décisions des juges
parce qu'effectivement là il y aurait un
risque qui est qui et qui est une forme
de confusion entre entre la procédure
devant le tribunal et la saturation
au niveau du fonctionnement du collège
bon nous avait répondu sur les
rémunérations des membres du collège il
ya des rémunérations qu'on peut
considérer comme
importante mais c'est tout à fait
logique compte tenu de l'importance de
la de votre haute autorité est aussi de
la nécessité de l'indépendance
est ce que les membres du collège je
continue à voir d'autres fonctions
à commencer par vous même je ne parle
pas de fonctions électives président est
plein temps
certains membres du collège ou au moins
dans la période initiale garder quelques
activités cliniques
soient des consultations essentiellement
des consultations et
actuellement il ya encore un membre du
collège qui garde une activité de
consultation qui donc ne travaille pas à
plein temps même s'ils travaillent
énormément et en particulier travail le
week-end pour préparer les réunions de
sa commission car il ya une commission
très lourde les textes qui ont institué
la chaise en prévu la mise à disposition
de fonctionnaires donc il ya
effectivement et c'est le cas auquel
fait référence le président il ya dans
le collège des fonctionnaires notamment
des fonctionnaires d éducation nationale
que sont les professeurs d'université
qui peuvent bénéficier ou demander à
bénéficier de ce statut de mise à
disposition pour conserver une valence
de l'ordre de leurs activités
cliniques et donc ils sont mises à
disposition sur suran 30e dont
l'occurrence actuellement il ya un
membre du collège qui mis à disposition
à 50% de 200 ans par l'assistance
publique des hôpitaux de paris mais
évidemment il y à une proportionnalité
des rémunérations il ne gagne pas pas
plus il ya il y à une disposition s'il
ya une disposition qui est prévu par les
textes lorsqu'un
fonctionnaire est mise à disposition
il reçoit il reçoit les traitements qui
sont liées à sa sens en activité
d'origine donc il n'est pas payé
directement en bourse les rémunérations
à 100 à sa son administration d'origine
et reçoit une rémunération pour services
rendus de
l'autorité de santé de 600 euros par
mois ces détections été fixé à l'origine
comme un boulet d'ailleurs donc c'est le
cas de ces le cadet des dpu bh qui sont
a mis à disposition et pour ce qui me
concerne j'ai gardé une petite
consultation je vois encore quelques
patients au centre anticancéreux de
nantes
vous avez évoqué tout à leur évaluation
médico-économique est ce que vous
pourriez nous en dire un peu plus la
fois sur ses buts sur ses sur ses
méthodes
oui alors
l'évaluation médico économique n'était
pas initialement prévus lors de la
création de la haute autorité de santé
qui devait en fait
indiqué l'état de l'art médical mais qui
ne devait pas se soucier de ce que cela
pouvait coûter à la collectivité
ça a été très vite rajouter puisque dès
le fss 2008 on a demandé à la haute
autorité de santé de fer d évaluation
médico-économique sur des grandes
stratégies
de santé publique et notamment sur les
stratégies de dépistage des maladies
infectieuses des maladies cancéreuses
alors quand on dit évaluation
médico-économique c'est principalement
l'évaluation du rapport entre le coût et
l'efficacité
depuis le pf sas 2012 efficacité en quel
sens pardon efficacité en quel sens
efficacité efficacité clinique du
médicament ou efficace j'allais y venir
notre mandat est par exemple une
stratégie de dépistage
prenons des différentes modalités de
dépistage du cancer du sein par exemple
qui est un des axes majeurs du plan
cancer et qui est
valorisé dans le cadre des
de la rémunération sur objectifs de
santé publique des médecins généralistes
dans le cadre de la convention avec
l'assurance maladie donc c'est un vrai
objectif de santé publique il ya deux
modalités il ya le dépistage organisé et
les dépistage individuel
eh bien on a fait une étude de
l'efficience de l'un par rapport à
l'autre c'est à dire de ce que ça coûte
par rapport à ce que ça sauve de vie et
donc on a considéré que le dépistage
organisé était plus efficient parce
qu'il était effectivement plus précis
que le dépistage individuel pour c'est
un exemplaire depuis 2012 on a une
nouvelle
mission dont je parlais tout à l'heure
puisque l'assumé sans moyens
supplémentaires qui est l'évaluation des
produits de santé il s'agit en fait
d'évaluer le rapport
coûts
l'efficacité c'est à dire généralement
un médicament nouveau et plus chers que
les médicaments anciens donc ce que nous
évaluons c'est le est ce que le surcoût
est justifié
par une augmentation du résultat et donc
on détermine
rapports entre l'augmentation du goût et
l'augmentation du résultat donc ce sont
des techniques médico économiques qui
sont
éprouvés qui viennent en fait
d'angleterre est pionnier en matière
d'évaluation et d'ical économique et
pour un certain nombre de médicaments ça
sert à la fixation du prix
ça n'est pas comme c'est le cas en
angleterre
une limitation aux remboursements en
angleterre quand un médicament un
rapport coût/bénéfice
qui est trop élevé quand le prix est
trop élevé pour le bénéfice attendu pour
le patient et pour la société
le médicament n'est pas pris en charge
en france c'est pas cela en france
l'évaluation que nous donnons sert au
comité économique des produits de santé
qui négocient les prix des médicaments
avec l'industrie pour fixer le prix donc
il ya un certain nombre de paramètres
qui l'utilisent notamment
l'intérêt médical ce que nous appelons
nous l'amélioration du service médical
rendu est l'évaluation médico économique
c'est à dire l'évaluation de du rapport
entre le coût et le résultat par
comparaison aux thérapeutiques
existantes donc avec ces évaluations
dvico économique le comité qui fixe les
prix peut discuter le prix exact de
super mastic et dire écoutez à ce prix
là c'est trop cher donc c'est en train
de se mettre en place
on a mis en a débuté au 1er janvier
2014 donc on a à peu près sans fin un
peu plus d'un an et demi de recul
on va dire que le travail qui est fait
est un travail de très grande qualité ce
que reconnaît à la fois le comité
économique des produits santé et des
industriels
il faut probablement que l'on renforce
l'utilisation de cet avis médicaux
économique notamment en le rendant plus
lisible pour les membres du comité qui
fixe les prix notamment en rendant
public
dès le vote définitif de la commission
ces avis pour l'instant une sont rendus
publics que lorsque le prix a été fixé
c'est-à-dire quelquefois plusieurs mois
après la délibération ce qui nous ennuie
nous souhaitons que ce soit
effectivement publié plus vite
nous souhaitons également en plus de
l'évaluation du rapport coût résultats a
ajouté ce qu'on appelle l'impact
budgétaire et je vous donne un exemple
qui va vous parler l'an dernier est
arrivé sur le marché français un nouveau
traitement d'hépatite c qui s'appelle le
sauve aldi qui a défrayé la chronique
parce qu'il est si cher il a généré des
dépenses de santé de plusieurs centaines
de millions au point que les
parlementaires que vous êtes ont voté
dans le cadre du plfss 2015 sortes de
mesures spéciales sur de plafond pour ne
pas aller au delà de certaines dépenses
ce sens que le les firmes n'y contribue
donc
on s'est rendu compte à cette occasion
que ce produit avait un rapport coût
efficacité très acceptable était très
cher mais il entraîne des bénéficies
important que son efficience est tout à
fait acceptable et la question qu'il
posait c'était la question de l'impact
budgétaire donc c'est à dire le
la différence entre ce que ça va coûter
à la collectivité est ce que ça peut
générer comme il
en arrive là au noeud du problème parce
que jusqu'à présent on peut que suivre
votre votre raisonnement mais vient un
moment où
comment dire les la problématique
coût efficace plutôt efficacité ou pas
du du médicament interfère avec la
problématique économique
de tous dans sa gestion de maladies dues
plus ou moins rares condé qu'on compense
compensera donc vous avez là à ce moment
là un joie banque de nature éthique qui
se fait sur l'idée est ce qu'on fait
quelque chose pour ce type de maladies
ou pas et on le fait oui ou pas en
fonction de quoi en fonction du bus
fonctionnent du coût économique parce
que c'est un peu ce qui se passe aussi
en angleterre parce que bon ce que vous
avez dit l'importation de ces méthodes
etc ça paraît tout à fait tout à fait
rationnel mais on se demande compte tenu
de l'air du temps si derrière il n'y a
pas cette idée que ma foi on voit
rationné
le plus raisonnablement possible
la centrale et des moyens de 2,2 de
santé une espèce de justifications plus
ou moins vaguement scientifique de ce
qui n'est jamais qu'un choix politiques
au bon sens du terme d'ailleurs un
goûter je suis médecin et qui plus est
je suis cancérologue donc j'ai été amené
à prescrire des médicaments extrêmement
chers dont certains d'entre eux en
bouleverser le pronostic des maladies
donc je suis avant tout intéressés ont
même je ne vais pas en cause
personnellement
qu'est ce que je vais vous dire de cette
problématique je vais vous dire que je
suis bien placé pour dire que ce qui
compte en premier c'est l'intérêt pour
le malade qu'est ce que ça va apporter
aux malades alors après force est de
constater que certains médicaments sont
très chers alors qu'ils apportent peut
donc l'évaluation médico économiques
cherchent à déterminer le juste prix
c'est à dire savoir ce que la
collectivité est disposé à payer en
fonction du bénéfice que ça apporte pour
le malade vous avez fait allusion des
maladies rares mais potentiellement très
grave et bien là le rôle de la hsc en
particulier le rôle de la commission de
transparence qui va lui l'intérêt
médical des produits c'est de savoir
quels services ça rend si ça rend un
service faible voire cosmétiques ça ne
justifie pas un prix élevé si ça sauve
des vies ça justifie un prix élevé même
si c'est sûr sur peu de malades et même
si c'est sur des traitements très
prolongée alors je veux insister sur un
fait premièrement à l'opposé de
l'angleterre
en france à ma connaissance il n'y a eu
aucun médicament
qui n'a pas été pris en charge par
l'assurance maladie pour des raisons
budgétaires
le nhs anglais
vient de décider début septembre
de supprimer du fonds spécial pour le
cancer
parce que les traitements anticancéreux
coûte très cher ben de supprimer une
vingtaine de médicaments dont certains
pour notre part en france sont
considérés comme les médicaments très
utile en france y'a pas ça y'a pas de
restriction
de rationnement pour des questions
budgétaires alors en revanche
l'évaluation médico économique sert à
fixer le juste prix est à dire aux
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
vous allez trop loin parce que on
comprend que
vous ayez la nécessité de faire des
bénéfices de créer de l'emploi de créer
de la recherche mais il faut aussi dire
que vous appuyez sur des systèmes de
santé que les systèmes de santé et ils
peuvent pas tout faire donc voilà on est
en train d'évoluer beaucoup sur
l'évaluation médico économique et
attendant de prendre de plus en plus de
poids et de toute façon il faut d'un
côté que l'industrie pharmaceutique
soit plus raisonnable qu'elle ne l'est
sur certains médicaments et il faut de
l'autre qu'on réfléchisse à
l'utilisation qui est faite de ces
médicaments et je pense que ce qui est
capital je vous le disiez madame la
présidente le rôle haute autorité de
santé cette facilité l'accès pour tous à
des soins de qualité à notre rôle c'est
de faire en sorte que le prix des
médicaments permettent de donner des
médicaments utiles à tous les malades
qui en ont besoin et quelquefois on est
amené à faire des choix je faisais
allusion aux sautes valdi le traitement
de l'hépatite c le collège de la haute
autorité de santé a rendu un avis en
2014 pour essayer de hiérarchiser les
prescriptions parce que on pouvait pas
dans la première année et traiter tout
le monde c'était un médicament très
utile mais était si cher qu'on pouvait
pas traiter tout le monde donc on a fait
une sorte de hiérarchisation des
urgences tout en reconnaissant qui
serait sans doute utile à terme de
traiter tout le monde on a dit les
malades qu'il faut traiter les plus vite
le plus vite sur ceux qui sont le plus
grave est donc notre rôle a été de
définir quels étaient les critères de
gravité qui permettait de traiter un
malade tout de suite donc voilà c'est ce
que la haute autorité de santé va être
amené à faire
définir des paramètres le plus précis
possible pour quantifier l'effet
clinique
développer des paramètres le plus précis
possible pour définir et c'est pas
toujours facile parce que c'est un
calcul mathématique puisque les mâles et
les médicaments n'ont pas encore été
prescrit donc on sert encore pas comment
ils vont rendre service en vie réelle
donc de définir de manière la plus
précise possible le rapport coût
efficacité pour essayer d'aboutir à des
prix raisonnables et ça peut
effectivement
si les firmes ne sont pas raisonnables
et si les prix sont trop élevés ça peut
effectivement aboutir à une situation
d'impasse et puis il faut aussi que nous
déterminions des critères de choix des
médicaments pour faire en sorte que l'on
puisse sélectionner les malades qui en
ont véritablement besoin mais c'est une
vraie question les le prix des
médicaments extrêmement cher et plus la
recherche progresse plus les médicaments
coûtent cher c'est une vraie question
notamment mais pas exclusivement dans le
domaine de la cancérologie et la
virologie
oui de questions
la première c'est les personnes les 400
personnes de la haute autorité de la
santé ce sont les des
fonctionnaires détachés ou est ce que ce
sont des contractuels
et puis deuxième question comment vous
situez-vous au niveau européen ou
mondial par rapport à peut-être
d'autorité qui existe je vais c'est
dominique maigne répondre à la première
question et je revois la deuxième saison
la spécificité de la haute autorité et
au cendre aussi des agences sanitaires
c'est c'est d'avoir favorisé la logique
professionnelle sur les parcours et
d'avoir plus grande donc recruter des
professionnels issus des différents
secteurs dans lequel elle est la
démission donc
tous les salariés de la haute autorité
sont tous des contrats de travail ce qui
n'empêche pas pour certains d'entre eux
d'être détaché en tant que fonctionnaire
mais ils sont où ceux recrutés sur
contre as etc c'est
la règle la règle de
constitutive dans le cadre d'un décret
qui a été prévu comme tel pour les
agents sanitaires qui date de 2003 tout
le monde et tout le monde est titulaire
d'un contrat sauf les membres du collège
qui sont ils sont dans une situation
particulière
alors pour la relation avec des
institutions comparables
dans d'autres pays jouait d'abord dire
que nous sommes une institution qui a le
champ de mission le plus large dans le
monde
j'ai cité les anglais les anglais ont
une institution qui est proche de la
nôtre s'appelle le nice qui en
particulier évaluent
leur permet au résultat des médicaments
et des dispositifs médicaux et les actes
médicaux il donne des recommandations de
bonne pratique donc ces démissions qui
sont comme les nôtres mais il n'a pas la
mission de certifier des établissements
de santé donc il ya à ma connaissance
aucune institution au monde qui a autant
de responsabilités que la nôtre et vous
pourrez regarder le budget du nice est
beaucoup plus élevé que le nôtre mais en
plus le nice sous traitent avec des
structures académiques pour une partie
de ces évaluations c'est juste pour
insister sur le fait que nous
travaillons finalement vous
alors oui on a des rapports avec les
institutions
comparable au nôtre
à vrai dire on a peu de rapport avec
les états unis parce que le système
sanitaire est complètement différent
mais en revanche on a beaucoup de
rapport au niveau européen alors d'abord
des rapports un peu privilégiés avec les
anglais les allemands on a mis en place
c'était mon prédécesseur qui avait mis
en place ça et nous continuerons à le
faire des réunions annuelles
actuellement qui ont été un moment
semestriels avec le nice anglais est
équivalent allemand qui s'appelle li
krieg mais surtout nous sommes
jamais dire
les
plus actifs
dans un réseau européen
d'évaluation des projets de santé en
anglais évaluation des pôles de santé
s'est écrié health technology assessment
et donc il ya un réseau européen qui
s'appelle le réseau
réseau européen d'évaluation des projets
de santé hewlett et chantier qui associe
toutes les institutions comparables au
nôtre qui travaillent donc sur
l'évaluation des médicaments des
dispositifs médicaux et notamment les
deux que j'ai une cité donc quand je dis
qu'on joue un rôle majeur c'est que on a
été à l'initiative
de
la regroupement
destiné à
uniformiser les évaluations il va de soi
que nous n'intervenons pas nous haute
autorité de santé aucune des autres
agences intervient sur l'autorisation de
mise sur le marché amm autorisation de
mise sur le marché c'est l'agencé
européenne du médicament ema qui serait
londres qui donne l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché pour tous les pays en
revanche chaque pays a sa politique de
santé chaque pays en europe à ces grands
axes chaque pays a ses possibilités
financières et donc le remboursement et
le prix des médicaments varient d'un
pays hôte est ce que nous avons essayé
d'uniformiser c'est les méthodes qui
aboutissent aux décisions donc faire une
évaluation la plus commune possible donc
on a mis un poing c'est la france qui
l'a fait c'est la chaise qui la ferme
mis en place des recommandations pour
évaluer de manière homogène les
médicaments et après les institutions
sanitaires prennent leur décision mais
l'évaluation des communes et puis
surtout on a développé quelque chose qui
marche très bien j'espère que ce sera
prolongée car tout ceci est faisable
grâce à une dotation budgétaire de la
communauté européenne la commission
européenne donc j'espère que ça sera
prolongée mais on a mis en place ce
qu'on appelle des evala sur précoce qui
consiste à travailler avec des
industriels pour leur dire voilà comment
vous devriez développer votre médicament
pour faire en sorte de mieux démontrer
l'intérêt de pouvoir aboutir rapidement
à une mise à disposition de ce produit
et à la fixation de son remboursement de
son prêt donc voilà il ya des joueurs il
ya aussi un réseau de la qualité des
soins
pareil européens et on a été les leaders
de ceux de ce réseau les dialogues
précoces sont inscrites dans le projet
de loi de santé
oui merci la présidente président
intervient suite à ce que vous êtes nous
avait dit tout à l'heure
et ça m'a effectivement un peu à peu
troublé
ce avait annoncé vous étiez médecin je
savais pas mais
très bien
et que vous pensiez d'abord aux patients
je crois que c'est effectivement normal
je crois qu'on pourrait on pense tous
qu'on soit gestionnaires
d'établissements conçu un médecin quand
soi-même qu'on ait des responsabilités
politiques nous pensons d'abord à nos
concitoyens et à faire en sorte qu'ils
soient mieux soigner possible
et je crois que ce n'est pas antinomique
entre la qualité des médicaments
mais je trouve que la position de la
france me semble curieuse
tout simplement parce que nous avons
tous intérêt à voir les meilleurs
médicaments possible pour ap hm pour
apporter le meilleur soin possible à nos
patients
la prescription elle est libre en france
le médecin prescrit ce qu'il veut
si on se contente simplement quand le
médicament est moins bon que d'autres de
renégocier avec le laboratoire le prix
du médicament
on ne change pas grand-chose sur un plan
économique parce qu'il continuera à être
prescrits et continuera à être en bourse
à chiens convaincu monsieur le sénateur
donc moi j'ai le sentiment que la
méthode anglaise à condition qu'elle
soit fait avec intelligence
me paraît aller dans un meilleur sens
pour essayer de trouver des économies à
notre sécurité sociale que le système
français vous me permettrez après avoir
entendu ce que vous avez dit de vous le
dire et tout compte fait ça m'amène à
une deuxième question qui n'a rien à
voir strictement rien à voir
je suis dans mon âme en bretagne
président d'un ehpad comme beaucoup de
mes collègues élus locaux
dans le cadre de la commune c'est-à-dire
dans le cadre du ces crs mais il existe
des ehpad associative il existe des
ehpad hospitalière et nous avons un réel
problème de surmédication au niveau des
personnes âgées est-ce que ça relève du
champ de votre structure
bien sûr j'ai répondre aux deux
questions qui sont extrêmement
importantes
la première question
d'abord je suis pas certain que votre
admiration du système anglais soit
justifiée lorsque le système anglais
abouti et du rationnement le fait qu' on
ne donne pas la possibilité aux patients
anglais d'avoir accès à des médicaments
très efficaces au motif qu'ils sont trop
chers ne serait pas admissible en france
deuxièmement je partage votre point de
vue concernant le fait que quand un
médicament est moins bon il ne doit pas
être remboursé la collectivité n'a pas à
rembourser un médicament qui est moins
bon que ce qui existe alors en théorie
dans le code de la sécurité sociale
la chasse fait son évaluation et si un
produit
à n'apporte pas d'amélioration par
rapport à ce qui existe il doit être
moins cher que ce qui existe mais il est
admis alors pour aller plus loin et
quand je dis que vous allez dans mon
sens moi je milite depuis trois ans
maintenant
sur une évaluation du médicament qui
choix purement comparative qui n'évalue
pas un médicament dans l'absolu mais
qu'il évalue par rapport à ce qui existe
et ça permettrait de dire si un
médicament est meilleur évidemment le
prend on discute de prix si un
médicament est égal on le prend mais il
doit être moins cher et si un médicament
est moins bon on ne prend pas
ce mythe pour ça il ya actuellement une
réflexion en cours à la demande de la
ministre qui est dirigée par une
économiste de santé dominique wolton
la solution que je propose est une des
solutions qui sont discutés on verra ce
qui finalement est proposée par la
deuxième question est capital il ya
effectivement en france comme dans
beaucoup de pays du monde
on n'est pas les seuls à faire du
mauvais usage
over yeuse un usage excessif
c'est vrai que dans les ehpad il ya un
usage excessif de tous les médicaments
mais en particulier des somnifères et la
haute autorité de santé a travaillé
depuis 2007 sur le mésusage des
somnifères notamment de la classe des
benzodiazépines chez le sujet âgé parce
que ça entraîne un certain nombre
d'effets secondaires dont certains
peuvent être graves comme des les
troubles de la conscience ou des chutes
qui générait des complications et
partenaires très grave après donc oui
c'est notre rôle puisque le rôle de la
haute autorité de santé c'est de définir
la qualité des soins et la sécurité des
patients et le mauvais usage des
médicaments ça génère j'ajoute que nous
avons depuis ce mandat
rajouter comme objectif fois la haute
autorité de santé l'efficience j'en ai
beaucoup parlé cette famille donc la
qualité et l'efficience il ya le mauvais
usage des médicaments entraîne deux
conséquences
probablement des dépenses de santé
injustifiée
donc il faut qu'on travaille le fait
c'est une de nos priorités sur la
pertinence des actes pertinence des
séjours hospitaliers la pertinence des
prescriptions et il faut que
travaille aussi là dessus parce que la
deuxième conséquence c'est
éventuellement des effets secondaires
liés à des prescriptions excessives ou
des prescriptions non adaptés donc oui
on est en plein dans nos
dans nos responsabilités et on a d'assez
nombreuses productions qui sont destinés
à éviter le mésusage
on a bien sûr les recommandations
professionnelles de santé on a des
fiche de bon usage du médicament
on travaille nous certifions les
logiciels d'aidé à la prescription et
pour les pharmaciens dead à la
dispensation donc on a beaucoup d'action
qui vise à aider la prescription
médicamenteuse
unique mais je le serai pas reçu un faux
jeu dominique mais il me dit on
travaille actuellement sur un aspect
très important qui est la conciliation
pharmaceutique la conciliation des
médicaments pour faire en sorte que
malade clientes dans un établissement de
santé
hôpital seo ou un ehpad arrivent
généralement avec des ordonnances et si
on n'a pas fait l'effort de savoir ce
qu'il prend on risque de lui prescrire
des médicaments qui peuvent
éventuellement est un organisme où il
entend être dangereux s'ils sont donnés
à l'association donc on travaille sur ce
qu'on appelle la conciliation des lakers
beaucoup de sujets qui sont alors en
plein dans vos préoccupations
notre problème est en fait de faire en
sorte que nos recommandations soient
suivies d'effets j'ai fait allusion au
travail de 2007 sur les benzodiazépines
chez le sujet âgé pour être très honnête
la prescription de benzodiazépines en
2015 n'a que très faiblement diminué me
semble-t-il donc nos pour nos
prescriptions
publication de recommandations ne sont
pas probablement assez suivie d'effet
direct avec les patients les malades les
citoyens est-ce que vous recevez alors
si direct c'est un patient en
particulier la réponse est non à nous
avons des relations privilégiées et
volontaire avec les associations de
patients agréé et or mis en place une
politique d'ouverture vers les patients
ou les usagers qui
repose sur d'abord la rédaction
d'ouvragés qui leur sont destinés même
si je dois reconnaître que
devrait aller plus loin et on a décidé
mettre en place une commission de
l'information des usagers pour justement
apporter des documents qu'ils soient
plus facilement compréhensibles par eux
deuxièmement
nous avons
ce site d'information des usagers sur la
certification des établissements de
santé dont je parlais tout à l'heure
troisièmement nous avons une réflexion
en cours sur ce que nous appelons la
décision partagée c'est à dire de donner
des recommandations aux patients mais
aussi de l'information de aux médecins
mais aussi de la formation aux malades
pour qu'ils puissent savoir quelle est
sa maladie qu'ils puissent poser les
bonnes questions à son médecin et qu'ils
puissent participer et plus à la
décision qu'il concerne enfin et c'est
très important depuis le départ nous
avons dans nos commissions des usagers
qui sont considérés comme des experts à
part entière c'est à dire qu'ils ont à
la fois les avantages des experts cela
comprend leurs frais de déplacement en
charge ils ont un petit défraiement
comme les autres experts mais ils ont
aussi les mêmes contraintes qui sont en
particulier obligé de signer une
déclaration publique d'intérêts puisque
certaines associations de patients
vivent avec des subventions de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
nous avions beaucoup milité pour que les
patients soient présentes dans toutes
nos commissions c'était le cas pour
celles qui sont alain la responsabilité
dont la composition des responsabilités
hs ce n'était pas le cas pour deux
compositions pour deux commissions
pardon dont la dent dont le nom vient
nous n'avions pas la main sur la
composition de ces commissions
c'est la commission qui évalue les
médicaments la commission de
transparence et la commission qui évalue
les dispositifs médicaux et
un décret vient de paraître qui change
la composition de ces commissions qui
introduit selon nous réjouissons les
représentants des patients que membre à
part entière de ces commissions
voilà pour cette audition de
représentants de la haute autorité de
santé auditions qui se tenait dans le
cadre des travaux de la commission d'
enquête sur les autorités
administratives indépendantes une
commission d enquête qui a été créée à
l'initiative du groupe rdse et kader
pour rapporteur le président de ce même
groupe jacques mézard les missions de
cette commission d' enquête est bien
c'est de ce nice youn et de façon
exhaustive la quarantaine d' autorité
administrative indépendante qui existe
en france des autorités qui ont un
pouvoir très important dans notre
système institutionnel est d'ailleurs la
mission de cette commission denquête
c'est de voir si ces autorités n'ont
justement pas trop de pouvoirs notamment
au détriment des pouvoirs législatif et
exécutif
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire à 18 heures
pour la suite des travaux de la
commission d' enquête sur les autorités
administratives indépendantes
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires